Photographers frequently refer to something
called color temperature; color temperature
is saying something about the spectrum of
the light that they are looking at in terms
to the equivalent black body radiator. So
the spectrum associated with this red sunset
is equivalent to a black body radiator of
about 2000 to 3000 degrees kelvin. It is a
very reddish light. A tungsten light is equivalent
to a color temperature of around about 3000
kelvin. The spectrum of the sun at midday
is equivalent to a black body radiator of
around 5000 to 5400 kelvin. A photographer
would say that the sunlight is bluer then
the tungsten light, or we can say tungsten
light is more red then the midday sun.
In the case of an overcast day, the color
temperature is, in fact, even higher, the
point in the world is no longer illuminated
by the white light from the sun, it is illuminated
by the blue light from the sky and this excess
amount of blue in the light is equivalent
to a much, much hotter black body radiator.
So a photographer would refer to this as a
color temperature in the range 8000 to 10 000
kelvin.
Our sun is a very hot object in space and
functions as a black body radiator, but by
the time the light from the sun finds its
way down to ground level the spectrum has
been dramatically altered and that is because
of a number of chemicals in the atmosphere—we
have ozone, oxygen, water, carbon dioxide
and so on—and each of them remove parts
of the radiation that comes from the sun.
So by the time the light gets to the ground
the spectrum is a little bit different from
an ideal black body radiator. The peak of
the spectrum of a light by the time it reaches
the ground is around about
550 nanometers … it is a little green color
and, not surprisingly, that is the color that
our eyes are most sensitive to.
A lot of the energy that comes from a black
body radiator is emitted in parts of the spectrum
that we cannot see in these longer wavelengths,
and this is one of the reasons that these
tungsten light bulbs are being phased out.
They convert some of the electrical energy
into light that we can see, but they convert
an awful lot of it into heat which does not
help us to see. They are not particularly
efficient.
So there is a lot of energy being omitted
at these longer wavelengths, so if we look
at this spectrum here, we can see that the
visible part of the spectrum, that region
between 400 and 700 nanometers, is actually
a very small part of the overall electromagnetic
spectrum.
With our eyes we are able to sense electromagnetic
radiation in this very narrow part of the
overall spectrum.
Although we cannot see infra-red radiation,
we can still sense it and we can feel it as
heat, as warmth on our skin. Infra-red radiation
was discovered by William Herschel, a German-born
English astronomer back in the 1700s. He built
an enormous telescope and discovered many
stars and planets.
And one day he took the light from his telescope
passed it through a prism onto a table and
he put a thermometer into different parts
of the spectrum on the table. He was trying
to measure the temperature of blue and yellow
and violet and red.
And what surprised him was that when he put
the thermometer into an area of the table
where he couldn’t see any light, the thermometer
still recorded a high temperature, so there
was radiation that was heating the thermometer
but he was unable to see it, so he discovered
infra-red radiation. He referred to them as
calorific rays.
I mentioned before that we can sense infra-red
radiation as heat. There are devices called
thermal cameras and they are very sensitive
to this infra-red radiation in what is called
the thermal or long
infra-red band between 9 and 14 micrometres.
That is 9000 to 14 000 nanometers, the units
that we were using previously.
And in that part of the spectrum human beings
omit energy, and so you can see that people
here are warm against a colder background.
This is our natural body temperature, 37 degrees
Celsius, it means that we ourselves are black
body radiators and we are omitting not much
but a small amount of
infra-red energy and a thermal camera can
pick this up. Thermal cameras are often used
to diagnose heat loss from buildings; the
outside of a building should be cool, but
if there are hot spots it generally tends
to indicate the heat is leaking from inside
the building to the outside world.
The fire beetle is exquisitely sensitive to
infra-red radiation. It likes to lay its eggs
into burnt trees, so it goes hunting for forest
fires and to do that it uses special infra-red
sensing organs built into its thorax.
There are also a large number of non-black
body illuminance: light omitting diodes, for
instance, have got a spectral characteristic
like this quite differently shaped to the
black body omission spectrum, so here we can
see the omission of a blue LED, a green LED
and a red LED.
We see that the energy concentrated into a
fairly narrow spectral band. There is no wasting
of omission in the infra-red part of the spectrum,
for instance.
A compact fluorescent tube has got a very
complex spectrum: the light is a mixture of
the light omitted by a large number of different
phosphors, the white layer inside the helical
tube which is excited by the gas discharge.
So each phosphor emits light at a different
wavelength. The overall combination of these
different wavelengths appears to our eye to
be white. Another non-black body illuminate
is the laser; the laser is perhaps somewhat
similar to the light omitting diode that we
looked at a moment ago, except that the spectrum
is extremely narrow. Finally, these are the
specular emissions associated with the red,
green and blue phosphors in an old fashion
cathode ray tube and this shows the emission
spectrum of the blue phosphor, this curve
here; the green phosphor, this curve here;
and the red phosphor which contains a large
number of quite narrow band emissions, but
together collectively they appear to the human
eye as red.
As I mentioned a moment ago, the light that
reaches the surface of the planet is partly
absorbed by various molecules in the atmosphere
of the planet. Water, in particular, is a
very strong absorber of light. This graph
shows the amount of absorption of light as
a function of wavelength and we can see that
there is a region of the spectrum where there
is minimal light absorption. If we look just
at the visible band and then mark blue and
red we can see that red light is absorbed
more than blue light and this explains why,
when you are under water and the further you
go under water, the light has got much more
of a blue tint to it—you tend to lose colors
like red and green, they tend to disappear
and everything starts to look blue because
only the blue light is able to penetrate through
a big column of water. So let’s summarise:
we have light that comes from an illuminate
and it produces illuminance of the scene and
we can describe that light in terms of its
spectrum, so we use the symbol E to represent
the luminance and it is a function of the
wavelength, and we have looked at various
sorts of illuminance, we looked at black body
radiators, light emitting diodes, compact
fluorescent tubes and lasers, each of these
have got a different spectral characteristic.